5 millones de personas tienen prohibido
salir de casa y las calles de shanghai
permanecen vacías pero la paciencia se
acaba y los residentes de este edificio
gritan que necesitan comida
si las cosas siguen así habrá problemas
la preocupación es que no tenemos ni
idea de cuánto va a durar el bloqueo
mientras que este vídeo parece mostrar a
un drone mandando un mensaje
hagamos los vídeos están siendo
censurados en las redes sociales chinas
repercusiones de no respetar las
estrictas normas del país el personal
sanitario los repartidores de comida los
voluntarios y los que tienen un permiso
especial son los únicos que pueden
circular libremente aunque el personal
trabaja las 24 horas del día la política
de 'tolerancia cero' de china ha
provocado dificultades para que los
alimentos lleguen a la población
empujando a algunos hacer un llamado a
los funcionarios un hecho insólito en el
país
escuchen nos nos estamos quedando sin
suministros no podemos comprar nada
el único momento en que los residentes
pueden salir de casa es para hacerse las
pruebas las personas que hayan tenido
contacto con alguien contagiado se ven
obligadas a aislarse
las autoridades se apresuran a construir
más camas para las instalaciones de
cuarentena algunos enfermos por kobe 19
están siendo alojados en edificios sin
duchas y en donde las luces permanecen
encendidas día y noche
el presidente jean ping reiteró el
miércoles que las medidas estrictas
deben continuar y que la persistencia
dará sus frutos